over the last few years many people have
changed careers and reevaluated that
work life balance what it looks like to
them and now companies are responding
okay this story
blew my mind and this is like now my
favorite company
listen to this cnbc reports a tech
company called seven rooms is offering
incredible incentives to their employees
for new hires they offered two fully
paid weeks off before they even start
that's two free weeks at full pay to do
whatever they want
and that's not all all employees must
take five consecutive days off at least
twice a year and long time employees
must double that by taking 10
consecutive days off twice a year
thought
i mean
are are you hiring because that's
i mean i'm not going anywhere but that
is sort of it tells people who want to
work at this company right away we value
you you know what i mean we value you
and as an employee that is so important
and so different to hear
this story really took my breath away
and i just think
seven rooms let this work you could be
the origin story to a new model
where we
allow people a life and we reward them
for it and we feed their
you know
soul and interest and we give them
things to look forward to and
plans to make and take some of the
financial burden out of it and i wonder
if it will bring
more
you know sort of focus and passion in
their job because
they feel respected and incentivized
absolutely i just love this tone
this is like it is we value you from the
get-go i love it
i love it i hope this is a success and
the first of many to follow
[Music]
you